okay so let's I can't use my bare hands
I'm bound only by the paper thin wrapper
okay that was a soul here like yeah you
goddamn psyched out then to be free and
so it shall okay just wanna get my side
house where we go failure okay this is
so [ __ ] so we just Shh yeah I mean you
already looked dead was he a mummy or
something I don't really know what
happened to you nice bathroom thanks
dick all right back so that's all I have
to do that what of it we offer several
travel package upgrades and you care yes
hope this guy's good no no y-you know
Manny I could make this car little
faster and her if you wanted yeah yeah I
don't care about the speed of car to the
lead you to modify it sick that'll be
fully [ __ ] sick i I'm so sorry i just
did that everyone please forget that
ever happens you rest this way mr.
Martinez can be safely padded by the
foam created when there's two chemicals
be cool like this on second thought I
would upgrade my package sorry Bruno Oh
qualify for anything he didn't even get
the gear to stick have this
complimentary oh that's nice wait I'll
get you find me something where I can
move my legs you know I'd like to Bruno
huh but my mom yes that's true hard-ass
I gotta be a hard-ass when i got lazy
sick of waivers like this jolly boy
working for me Manny you couldn't find a
sale at a yacht club I got a sale right
here I'm looking premium sales caliber
like it's not my fault the system is
claw is supposed to make premium sales
with the scumbag clients you're sending
me hey now you're blaming the clients
I've had it with you Manny if you
haven't bagged a premium before the next
sales report comes in you're out out on
the [ __ ] no job no way to work off your
time just your fancy suit and your big
smile and a whole lot of time to kill
cool many who you callin us scumbag oh
man I can't believe this is a video game
this is so different to anything else
and I've ever played in a beautiful
beautiful way sick a waitin oil for a
good lead like it's gonna fly in here
tied to a brick it's time to removing
now no oh okay back up here I guess uh
okay hey can I use the hole punch yeah
no still no oh yeah let's say that you
know kielbasa not really in his office
sweetheart I know what your run new huh
you're trying to get me away from my
desk so you can link on my facebook
together again oh I love him okay yeah
yeah you missed a great poisoning yeah
and you missed a great client Domino
came back from all other than none
equally I got a tiny little man with a
mean temper and no commission well at
least you don't work for 10 I'm een I do
though kind of really don't I um yeah I
don't know
I can't find my driver Manny do I have
to explain your job to you again no no I
just want to know where my driver is do
you want me to have him paint yeah page
the [ __ ] yes then get done to stop
being bought the cheap skate in the
stall a paging system you're just gonna
have to troll the carpool until you find
a demon with a driver's license ah ok
what now gotta go hit the bricks Oh ah
what is that horrible squeaking noise
you're making new shoes oh it's my pet
cat you want to see it check it out
isn't it beautiful see oh that's what's
not terrible I mean actually it is a
little bit annoying do you like it do
you like it the fact that she noticed it
means I need it right that means it's
significant I think let's go visit the
balloon guy again and be like sup bruh
no [ __ ] idea what I'm doing but thank
you but is sick cat [ __ ] and love the
noise it makes I totally know you and
your fancy suits and your nose holes way
up in the air sticking your empty beer
bottles down the mezzanine tubes how
fancy is that oh don't you boys upstairs
realize then hoops Witcher is a
sophisticated and delicate piece of
machinery huh you think you're perfectly
fine good wow that dudes angry um but I
mean I would totally use the tube
switcher for that too putting beer
bottles in it if I drank beer there's
not a thing that I drink often much
prefer cider but you know I can
understand this here [ __ ] skeleton
being into beer was that conversation
relevant somehow maybe there's like a
bin somewhere maybe we have to like make
it up to him or I don't know maybe it's
just weld building like really though I
think this game is [ __ ] awesome
um in that the universe is yes so alone
so let's go back to this guy hey brand
you talk to me I still know oh yes huh
okay sure my kid wants another balloon
animal she's what now yes did you lose
the one I gave you oh well then just
enjoy it for a while longer all right
obviously I want dead 11 heck that's
it's just is it just a pollutant pull it
out of his office he pulled that out of
sauce there's no i'm at uno's can I have
another one you know then I have a dead
worm now hey uh I don't know idea what
to do um maybe I can get Robert who's
Robert can I have one of him so much
yeah miss work don't you think spark and
I not may be right what if I pull out
the dead worm then do I get to boss for
Robert yeah my kid wants another balloon
animal geez what now I won't rub it
frost Robert Frost try in the step [ __ ]
he's gonna do it he's gonna do it that
looks like a deformed trumpet I don't
know I don't know who Robert Frost is
but ah look it's a this is definitely in
the face of a dude with a pipe well
that's cool I guess my kid loves this
balloon animal of this dude with this
[ __ ] pipe all right uh I don't know
what to do yep again you guys no [ __ ]
idea what to do oh well keep this phone
i SAT short and I will bask in my
lostness for the next I don't know half
hour until I figure [ __ ] out and can
record again for you guys actually no
wait we'll check out this little
trapdoor thing over here first if
anything happens hang on but first I
need to pull out my cat I can't cat
please can't function without it so you
know you can't just walk down creepy car
doors without get squeaky pink cat okay
just do anything yet pedo hey that has a
hole in it what's that can I put things
in it let's put a dead one minute that's
no loser for I'm pretty sure they Allah
that's not what balloons are for mm-hmm
all right get a baskin being lost we'll
get back to you guys when i sold my [ __ ]
out